une production du studio
SF bienvenue sans filtre le podcast on
parleit PL un honneur
deevoir deevir l'homme le plus en forme
de la planète
jeffreler qui vient de gagner crossit
Games qui est la plus relevé la comp la
plus relev de
crossfitis une compétion finalement qui
met teste finalement toutes les
aptitudes physiques de l'être humain
dans le fond de d'un effort de force de
de de soulever des des des charges
d'altérophilie à des 5 km de course 5 km
de course 40 minutes de vélo vraiment
finalement un test complet de de la
forme physique Jeffrey Adler qui a
remporté pour la première fois les
CrossFit Games c'est sa 5è participation
qui est venu aujourd'hui avec sa coach
Caroline qui était aussi sa blonde alors
on a eu les deux aspects autant de
l'intérieur avec l'athlète que son coach
un peu la la stratégie d'entraînement et
aussi on a parlé du Crossfit plus
largement de de de de la discipline de
de de la la la communauté finalement
puis c'est quoi finalement le CrossFit
c'est quoi l'approche c'est quoi les
avantages moi j'is je un CrossFitter moi
j' CrossFitter j'en fais un petit peu
moins j'en ai fait longemp puis c'est
vraiment une discipline que je respecte
puis que j'aime puis c'est un beau un
bel univers CrossFit ouais puis une
superbe rencontre c'est deux personnes
super down to là tu sais c'est comme il
vienent de gagner la plus grosse
compétition de CrossFit au monde sont
comme juste chill on a recommencé à
s'entraîner on est revenu au gym puis tu
sais vraiment cool des recevoir fait que
on espère que vous allez en tirer la
motivation et de l'intérêt fait que bon
podcast bon écoute le podcast est
présenté par vidéo créateur pro qui est
une initiative en fait qui est un vidéo
d'enseignement de de la vidéo finalement
une vidéo sur comment faire des vidéos
qui est gratuit qui sont faites par deux
de nos amis Henry et Niri qui viennent
souvent au studio ici qui avec qui on a
travaillé aussi sur un vidéo promo du
studio en fait eux c'est des vidéastes
professionnel puis là il révèlent enfin
leur truc on sait aujourd'hui la vidéo
c'est hyper important que vous soyez
créateur de contenu vous ayez une
business ou que peu importe ce que vous
faisz ce que vous que vous faites que
peu importe ce que vous faites euh avoir
des skills en vidéo comment faire une
bonne vidéo comment bien shooter comment
bien monter euh ça peut vraiment être
très très très utile donc c'est une
vidéo qui est gratuite qui du 45 minutes
qui vous donne il vous donne leurs 10
meilleures astuce pour amener vos vidéos
aux prochains Nau puis je vous entends
déjà dire pourquoi est-ce que
j'écouterais Henry et Niri ben Henry n
il ont une compagnie qui s'appelle
hxn qui est une compagnie de production
audiovisuelle avec qui on a déjà
travaillé nous pour le studio SF il
était venu ici euh puis avait fait une
vidéo deom de promotion pour notre notre
studio puis c'était absolument
impeccable pour vrai c'éit débile il on
aussi travaillé avec des grosses marques
comme la Croix Rouge ou encore wtier
cosmétique et aussi euh personnellement
en fait moi en mon nom j'avais une
collaboration avec sport expert pu sport
expert avait fait affaire pour cette
collaboration là avec
hhxen euh puis le résultat avait été
vraiment impeccable
c'est c'est ça av été un super projet
donc c'est vraiment des pros et si vous
voulez en apprendre plus sur la création
de vidéo professionnelle et vous-même
devenir des des amateurs/ash pro
s'entend vous allez devenir pro avec
leur formation ben allez voir le lien
dans la description du podcast merci
beaucoup au boys de nous encourager
Merci à VOUS d'encourager les boys qui
nous encourage ça fait du 360 fait que
bon podcast le podcast de cette semaine
est présenté par manscate mancate
manscate vous les connaissez c'est des
produit parfait pour l'entretien de la
pilosité de la peau des cheveux ça fait
partie de la pilosité aussi c'est nos
produits préférés et là le Beard Edger
ici qui est le leur nouveau Clipper en
fait pour la la barbe pourquoi je vous
parler de ça spécialement aujourd'hui
parce que si vous me regardez sur
Youtube en ce moment j'ai une moustache
OK puis comment je l'ai fait c'est avec
le Beard Edger parce queil y a 20 euh
longueur que vous pouvez choisir fait
que moi je veux pas je veux pas être sa
cuirette c'est joues sur le menton mais
en même temps j'ai pas beaucoup de poil
ses jou sur le menton fait je veux pas
qu'il soit plus long que la moustache
fait ce que j'ai fait je me suis mis les
joues le menton puis le triangle ici à 3
je me suis mis la stache à 6 puis ça
fait le look que vous voyez maintenant
qui est pas encore parfait parce que je
devrais continuer à le à le modifier on
pas mais qui est quand même incroyable
euh fait que ça c'est le nouveau euh kit
en fait le le kit de barbe Dom tu peux
peut-être m'en parler un petit peu plus
d'Ant oui parce que c'est pas juste on n
pas juste le clipper avec ça on a tout
un kit incroyable pour avoir la pilosité
parfaite puis une barbe en santé une
peau incroyable làdedans y a si étapes
on peut y aller là premièrement allons-y
B premièrement il y a un shampoing pour
la barbe qui sent vraiment bon moi je
l'utilise tout le temps dans douche en
fait je me champ la barbe après ça un
petit ping je vais le sortir
ouiou petit ping on se pigne pour
qu'elle soit bien lisse bien audio
incroyable bien droite après ça on peut
trier après ça on se finit avec un petit
ciseau qui va vraiment super bien aussi
une petite brosse on brosse ça puis
après ça on a une huile à barbe
incroyable avir une barbe luisante et en
santé bien nourri donc avec ça là vous
allez avoir une barbe pour les gouverner
tousit si vous voulez tester cette barbe
là pour les gouverner tous et tous les
autres produits chez mscap utilisez
notre code promo parce que ça
premièrement vous sauvez 20 % de Rabet
plus le shipping gratuit mais aussi ça
leur indique que vous venez de notre
podcast ça nous aide nous ça les aide
eux ça vous aide vous ça aide tout le
monde tout le monde gang fait utiliseer
le code sans filtre pour 20 % de rab et
le shipping gratuit puis merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mencap
ça roule merci d'être là merci de nous
avoir invité yes on parlait juste avant
on va juste continuer la conversation
qu'on a dans le fond juste avant qu'on
enregistre vous disiez que là c'est
c'est le retour à l'entraînement après
les les games ça fait 3 semaines de
vacances qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pendant 3 semaines de vacances comment
qu'on décroche de ça ouais ben on avait
beaucoup de rattrapage à faire parce que
pendant la saison surtout pendant l'été
moi je fais rien d'autre que m'entraîner
puis dormir et on a fait du rattrapage
un petit peu avec le Gym à maison des
trucs qu'on avait à faire on a fait
beaucoup de médias aussi pendant les
deux premières semaines on en a profiter
pour faire le maximum de médias possible
puis à un moment donné on était comme
bon ben là on un petit peu tanné fait
que on a décidé de de partir on on est
parti quelques jours dans charlevois yes
pour décrocher autant mentalement que
physiquement parce que j'imagine que la
recharge mentale est aussi importante
que la recherge physique sinon sinon
plus là ben pour moi cette année ça a
pas été tant mental que ça ben
honnêtement là je pense l'année passée
ça a été
pire ça dépend de l'été que je vis tu
sais cet été honnêtement il a pas fait
si chaud que ça euh il a fait humide
mais il y a pas fait si chaud que ça
comparé à l'année passée fait j'ai eu
moins de difficultés à m'entraîner les 6
à semaines avant avant les games euh
fait quand j'arrive aux Games ben je
suis pas autant détruit fait que j'ai
pas autant à récupérer après parce que
normalement comme après les games je
suis juste gen j'ai plus envie de
m'entraîner j'ai pas envie de bouger
j'ai pas envie je suis complètement puis
là cette année j'étais genre après une
semaine sa je pourrais repartir j'étais
correct sa mais physiquement j'avais
besoin de plus de temps cette année
ouais parce que ça va-être tellement
demandant tu sais quand qu'on qu'on
savait qu'on qu'on recevoir j'ai regardé
les les les toutes les tests dans le
fond GAM puis à chaque fois j'étais
comme ça pas de bon qu' fasse comme
c'est genre 5 jours dans le fond 4 jours
4 jours c'est encore pire à trois tests
par jour ouais puis ça va tellement être
taxant physiquement là on va parler
probablement de l'entraînement puis tout
ce que ça prend mais les 4 jours là ça
ressemble à quoi ces journées là en
terme de genre récupe repos tout le le
protocole pour être capable d'être à ton
meilleur pendant toutes ces foisl c'est
ça qui est le plus tof surtout quand il
y en a trois par jour c'est ça qui est
vraiment dur à deux par jour c'est pas
si pas sais parce tu en fais un à mon je
sais pas fin d'avantmidi puis tu en fais
un fin d'après-midi tu as une C d' h tu
peux aller te coucher tôt tu es pas
obligé de te lever tôt fait deux là
comme pendant les semis c'est vraiment
manageable tu es s tu es raqué à fin
puis c'est correct là mais trois par
jour pendant 4 jours là c'est c'est
c'est une toute autre game faut
s'assurer que tu manges assez faut
trouver une façon de entre les workout
de pouvoir relaxer puis comme tout
descendre pour pouvoir remonter une
deuxième fois puis toute le refaire pour
remonter une troisème fois puis le soir
en arriv à la maison c'est tu manges
jusqu'à temp que tu sois plus capable de
rentrer à fourchette dans ta bouche puis
après ça tu vas te coucher tu sais c'est
à peu près ça que c'est c'est ça le
mangur ça rendre malade
quasiment c'est ça qui est honnêtement
moi je trouve le plus tof rau dimanche
là c'est la la bouffe veut juste plus
rentrer tell le plus possible le plus
que tu es capable parce que même si je
me force en compétition mon appétit est
diminue beaucoup je mange déjà pas assez
parce que mon appétit est trop basse
fait faut je force feed par-dessus puis
c'est ça qui est vraiment t puis je suis
même pas proche de ce que je mange
normalement il faut que je force feed
fait que c'est c'est ça qui est qui est
quand même tough là tu sais je voudrais
tout boire moi pendant les games je
boirais des calories liquides ouais mais
tu peux pas faire ça ton intestin va se
vir à l'envers ça sera pas trop long
fait faut faut manger du solide puis
c'est ça qui le plus dur à faire c'est
des épreuves de de combien de temps à
peu près l'épru de Mons CrossFit Games
c'est des
plus long 40 minutes 40 minutes de on a
eu 5 km le 4.6 de course cétait pas 5 km
ça sa 15 à 20 minutes m puis on
a
3 x 2 après ça on a eu skib bag qui
était quoi 5
minutes 5 6 minutes ça dépend ça
idéalement il y a de tout il y a du 3 4
minutes minutes du 9 10 minutes puis du
long là après ouais mais c'est ça
l'affaire parce que tu sais le titre
fitest on earth là c'est quand même
comme flashy puis genre un peu ça peut
avoir l'air un peu
genre salis puis marketing tu sais mais
essentiellement un peu ça tu sais parce
que là tu dis ton ton 4.6 de course tu
l'as quand même couru en 1640 ouais ce
qui est quand même relevé là tu sais mon
pb moi sur 5 kg c'est 1640 ouais moi CIT
4.6 je' je m'ignais je m'alignais pour
un 18 mais moi mon 5 kg est plus vite
que 18 pareil sur combien je suis dans
les
17 il y a des informations qu'on ne va
pas
révéleron va rester bag mais sa je Pise
200 livr aussi là mais non je sais c'est
c'est pour ça que tu sais mettons je un
petit peu plus vite que toi sur 5 kg
mais on s'entend que s'il fallait que je
fasse le Snatch on même pas dans même
dans le même univers là euh mais pour
être capable
d'enchaîner toutes ces épreuves là
toutes ces tests là en amont il y a de
la préparation à faire parce que c'est
toutes les zones c'est aérobique zone 1
c'est anaérobique c'est explosivité
c'est force max comment ça se prépare
moi c'est ça ma question comment on
réussi à toutes mettre les pièces du
puzzle ensemble parce que tu sais pas tu
sais jamais qu'est-ce que ça va être sa
tu sais nous on a fait la la comp de
natation puis tu t'entraînes pour une
épreuve tu t'entraînes pour le sang
libre tu le sais que telle journée tu
vas faire un sang libre tu sais puis tu
poses pas de question tu t'entraînes
pour ça tout ton plan fait par rapport à
ça mais en CrossFit c'est tellement
large le type d'épreuve qu' faire qu'
faut juste que tu sois en condition
physique incroyable dans tous les
domaines puis tuespères que comme
d'avoir des épreuves qui qui qui sont
les meilleur pour toi finement bah ça ça
fait partie un peu du Crossfit c'est
comme oui tu peux tomber chanceux avec
la programmation d'une compétition je
pense c'est c'est c'est c'est un des
côtés plat si on dit sa c'est facile de
s'entraîner pour un 100 m de natation
parce que tu sais exactement qu'est-ce
que tu vas faire exa mais tu sais c'est
ça qui fait aussi que j'ai des vraiment
longues journées comme quand je
m'entraîne ben faut que je fasse toutes
les ZES faut que je fasse toutes les
types de fibbres musculaire puis faut je
mélange des trucs ensemble parce que un
mouvement va créer une fatigue qui est
différente d'un autre on les mixe
ensemble pu on voit qu'est-ce qui arrive
puis on voit sont où les points faibles
sais fait qu'on essaie de voir si c'est
c'est quoi le limitant dans tel ou
épreuve ben ok ben il faut travailler
là-dessus un petit peu plus moi ça a
toujours été l'endurance comme qui était
pas tout à fait là j'ai toujours été bon
en endurance mais pas pas bon puis que
ça me coûte rien là cette année j'étais
bon puis ça me coûtait pas grandchose
d'être bon fait que c'est ça je pense
qu' a fait la grosse différence parce
que des deux épreuves de grosse
endurance fa que le vélo puis la course
tu finiss dans le pack de tête puis ben
si si ce que tu dis est vrai que ton ton
ton 5 kg était plus vite que le PA que
tu étais là mon mais c'est sûr que es tu
es moins dans à bloc ça pu c'est ça je
pense qui est vraiment important c'est
d'être assez bien entraîné pour quand tu
arrives tu fais l'épreuve tu es capable
de pas aller tout à fait à 100 % tu sais
comme je je run high mon heart rate sur
la course il était pas il était pas le
fun là tu sais j'éis dans j'étais dans
170 175 c'est comme ça te coûte quelque
chose mais si tu t'entraînes comme il
faut ça te coûte moins qu'un autre
peut-être pu c'est ça comme un peu qu'il
faut entraîner c'est de cette façon là
qu'il faut s'entraîner hm hm h puis à
quel point est-ce que la capacité de
récupérer à même les games un impact
sur tes performances versus les autres
mettons dans le sens est-ce que le
dernier test là si tout le monde le fait
fresh la journée 1 est-ce que le
résultat est sensiblement le même ou non
pas du tout ben ça dépend ça dépend ça
est-ce que les temps vont être le même
non il vont être plus rapide classement
m mais le classement pourrait être
similaire parce qu'en réalité les gars
qui sont sont bons dans ces workout là
vont toujours être bons même quand qu's
vont être complètement éclatés tu sais
fait c'est juste les temps aur probement
été un peu plus rapide les stratégie AA
t un petit peu différente aussi Mons si
je prends le dernier workout de cette
année il y en a qui seraient peut-être
allé plus fort sur le bik ou qui aurait
pris moins de break à certains endroits
mais c'est quand qu'on arrive à la fin
du weekend là on est magané pas mal puis
genre tu fais ce que tu peux là mais les
gars qui sont bons dans ce type de
workout là qui arrive à la fin va
toujours être bon qu'il soit fresh ou
complètement mais est-ce que vous
remarquez des fois tu
sais justement certaines personnes qui
pe-être une capacité de récupération
meilleure que là va à la fin des Games
ont mieux performé par rapport aux
autres qu'au début ou ou c'est pas
vraiment oui oui quand même ben on le
voit avec les warmup fait que ça nous
autres quand qu'on quand qu'on est avec
les les nos compétiteurs on regarde qui
qui se warm up parce que mettons les
premières journées tout le monde se warm
up pendant plus longtemps puis les
journée avance puis les warm up puis
c'est courte puis c'est cour pu c'est
cour ont le
goû c'est long dimanche si tu vois un
gars Quié il est éclaté lui c'est sû tu
comme c'est impossible qu' va te donner
une per de sa vie il y en a plus de jus
c'est fini tu sais puis cette année
c'était pas si les gars même rend
dimanche ça se war encore tu sais comme
je pense honnêtement on a eu overall
comme vraiment bon Games les gars
étaient en shape tout le monde était
prêt puis bien entraîné pour comparé à
d'autres années où gen on arriv la
dernière journée là puis ouis
complètement pété pu là personnees qui
se il font deux trois affaires puis s'en
sur le FL puis ferme les yeux pendant
une coupe de minutes mais non cette
année ça s'est bien passé a puis le le
le calibre à travers les années est-ce
que ça fait juste croîre puis c'est
juste comme en ascension puis le monde
le sport se développe pu les gens
deviennent meilleurs est-ce que c'est ça
depuis depuis le début bon quand
même oui je pense l'aspect récup c'est
ça qui s'améliore vraiment beaucoup dans
les dernières années les années vraiment
proche là je parle de 1 à 3 ans c'est là
où on voit que genre la récupe elle a un
rôle vraiment important puis les les les
gars prennent un petit peu plus de temps
pour focus là-dessus au lieu de juste
t'entraîner t'entraîner t'entraîner
comme là ou à un peu comme si tu
récupères tu peux t'entraîner moins
parce que tu peux genre donner la gomme
deux trois fois dans la journée au lieu
de te péter la face CIN fois fait que
c'est comme l'espèce de in between là
que qui qui commence à être intéressant
puis je pense que c'est ce mindset là
c'est façon de penser s beaucoup elle a
beaucoup évolué dans les derniers 2 ans
mon 2 3 ans h HM fait j'imagine
d'utiliser plus les les marqueurs comme
tu sais les les le HRV ces affaires là
c'est quelque chose qui avec lequel vous
travaillez vousut ou un peu tu sais ben
je porte ouais je porte la Whoop je
regarde ça un peu est-ce que je porte
attention à 100 % à toutes non tu sais
des fois je tombe dans le rouge un matin
puis je peux le savoir pourquoi la
veille j'ai maxé mon dead Liv comme
c'est sûr mon système nerveux vare chot
le lendemain fait que c'est pour ça je
suis dans le rouge je vais m'entraîner
pareil là ça change rien mais ça te
donne des indications tu sais de si tu
es si tu es en forme ou non là ça c'est
sûr ouais puis est-ce que tu planifies
l'entraînement en fonction de ça un peu
je vais faire des ajustement fait sa par
exemple justement on voit ce qui va
causer des chutes dans son HRV ou en
mauvaise nuit de sommeil ou quoi que ce
soit fait le fait qu'on qu'on travaille
ensemble ça permet de faire des
ajustements justement on thefly pour
s'assurer que Ben peut-être qu'on va
diminuer un peu le volume ou diminuer un
petit peu l'intensité pour être sûr que
cette journée làà tu puisses récupérer
pour que tu puisses te réentraîner fort
la journée d'après puis l'autre sais ça
me donne rien de juste continuer à
l'assommer avec du volume l'intensité
puis qui récupère jamais derrière fait
sans dire oh tu es une journée dans le
rouge justement ok on prend ça relaxe
quoi que ce soit non parce que ça
pourrait arriver en compétition fait que
je veux pas l'entraîner dans des dans
des conditions parfaites ça n'existe pas
puis on sait jamais ce qui va arriver en
compétition fait faut dealer avec mais
en même temps de m'assurer justement que
il y a une récupération qui se fait
derrière ou quoi que ce soit ou sa même
chose on tombe malade c'est l'hiver
arrive on au Québec tout le monde est
malade ben justement dans ces momentsl
c'est le fun d'avoir l'information de
est-ce que tu es vraiment récupéré
est-ce qu'on sort de cette période là ou
est-ce que tu es peut-être encore en
train d'incuber quelque chose ou quoi
que ce soit fait c'est un outil
intéressant mais c'est pas c'est pas ça
qui va dicter si on veut tout tout ce ce
qu'on fait là mais 4 jours de Game
j'étais dans le rouge fait
que contrairement à l'année passée ouais
ah ouais l'année passée c'était pas
sais je me levais rouge 16 % je comme ah
bon mais je F je Filis correct fa jeis
comme bon ben pas grave c'est une
variable aussi le lendemain 22 % oh ben
j'ai récupéré un peu CR le prendre puis
bah après tu sais la après dimanche puis
le lundi ben souent on prend de l'alcool
pu tout fait que là ça c'est roues
garantiou mais ça c'est pas
nécessairement ça pas nement transparu
dans tes performances j'imagine parce
que tu as gagné là fait ben un peu quand
même là je veux dire j'étais pas j'étais
pas fr comme rose m surtout après le
bike cétait quand même pas drôle mais tu
sais ça ça change rien au fait que genre
faut tu performes puis que tu sois dans
le rouge dans le jaune dans le vert ben
tuas pas le choix fa puis qu'est-ce qui
a changé de l'année passée où est-ce que
tu étais dans le vert c'est juste que tu
est allé plus à bloc cette année
peut-être je sais pas vraiment puis tu
sais comme des fois stress juste la
compétition comme ça c'est des choses
qui vont affecter ton Hach VI on pas
dans le même lit on éit pas dans le même
hôtel que d'habitude fait juste de
sortir un peu de ces habitudes là la
nourriture un petit peu différente si on
fait on a fait un plus de carb cette
année fait que c'est c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui affecter son système
fait c'est pour ça je dis c'est une
variable intéressante mais faut pas ah
je suis dans le rouge je ne performerai
pas non faut pas que mentalement ça l'a
fait mais fait c'est des choses comme ça
que puis justement ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'on l'a qu'on est capable de
de voir est-ce que c'est juste des
facteurs plein de petits facteurs qui
ont affecté que genre bon ça l'affece
pas ta performance ou justement tu s
malade parce que on le voit qu'on est
dans le rouge quelque chose non son R de
respiration est normal tout va bien tu
sais c'est juste c'est des choses comme
ça fait que c'est intéressant quand même
de de voir ça de le tracker ouais mais
moi c'est moi j'ai la tu sais j'ai la
bague là puis le le matin quand j'ai des
courses ou des compétitions je la
regarde pas parce que souvent c'est
genre le Cadrin à 4h du matin parce que
la journée commence bien trop de bon
heure pu là tu es comme tu bag dit tu en
train de
mourir tu commences ta course comme bon
ben que aujourd'hui que ça se
passe
démoralisant moi ça ça m'affit pas temps
parce que tu sais j'en ai des rouge ben
régulièrement j'en ai entre 1 et tr par
mois anyway puis comme ces journées là
souvent c'est des journées où je
m'entraîne c'est pas des journées où
est-ce que je suis à OFF puis je
m'entraîne pareil puis sais faut juste
faut tu all au ressenti tu sais tu
regardes c'est rouge tu es comme h mais
je suis quand même correct sais puis des
fois j'ai des veres je su comme je me s
vraiment pas ver puis fait c'est juste
comme faut tu all au feeling aussi sais
tu peux pas juste te baser sur qu'est le
Data que ça te donne ouais ouais ouais
tantôt ben pas je faisais la blague mais
vous c'était visiblement pas une blague
mais le c'est quoi le raisonnement de
pas dévoiler les les son son pb sur 5 kg
mettons c'est c'est pour garder un
avantage compétitif c'est c'est quoi le
oui par que d ce que vous voulez dire
vous êtes pas obligé de répondre
exactement si c'est c'est B de toute
façon des des des des person au B c'est
pas vraiment c'est pas relevant pour les
autres parce que tu es capable de le
faire ou tu es pas capable de le faire
sauf que pour certains trucs j'im mieux
le garder pour moi puis garder la
surprise sur le floor tu sais comme les
gens ils s'attendaient pas à quel point
j'allais courir vite sur le C puis moi
moi je le savais là puis j'étais je
savais quel temps que j'allais sortir là
puis c'est c'est juste surprenant pour
tout le monde comme oh shit Jeff il
court vite de même comme on l'a pas vu
là j'ai un petit peu comme ils vont le
savoir la prochaine fois ouis là tu pour
pas pas le cacher mais là tu sais siim
mon P aujourd'hui il est à 1830 puis
l'année prochaine il est à 1745 ben ça
va être encore plus violent là la
surprise fait que c'est juste de pas
donner trop d'information là je je
partage pas mes mes pibi ben ben mais tu
sais après je pense les seuls que je
partage vraiment c'est les lifts parce
que ça c'est très genre tu es capable ou
tu es pas capable comm tu ve tu peux pas
t'améliorer nécessement à ça il y a rien
que tu peux faire tu peux t'améliorer
mais tu peux pas essayer de faire moi
faut je m'améliore à ça parce que lui
estouis mais c'est ça j'essaie de garder
ça tu sais c'est pareil comme les VO2
tests comme moi j'ai mes VO2 test pour
toutes fait je sais exactement genre
c'est quoi mes heart rate pour chaque
zone je sais c'est en fait c'est juste
des choses que c'est un avantage pour
moi que je suis pas prête à à partager
pour les autres sais puis j'imagine que
tu sais dans l'entraînement aussi puis
c'est trouver un équilibre RRE toutes
les les différents types de de de de
disciplin d'entraînement parce que tu
sais j'imagine que tu pourrais
probablement améliorer encore ta course
mais peut-être que ça te coûterait
quelque chose tu dans le sens que tu
sais si tu perdais du poids probablement
tu courrais plus vite mais probablement
tu l très moins aussi fait que là c'est
c'est de trouver la parfaite balance
peut-être en toutes ces affaires là
justement fait que bah tu sais comme tu
vois là en C là genommence
tranquillement puis tu sais à date j'ai
couru 20 des 20 minutes des 25 minutes
on recommence avec des zones de très
slow puis c'est surtout ça qu'on va
faire puis on va augmenter le volume de
course lente
jusqu'à février février mars mon puis à
partir de ce temps là on commence là à à
rajouter plus du speed sais fait qu'on
on builde comme une grosse base de
cardio pendant
l'hiver fait l'année passée je l'ai fait
puis j'ai pas perdu tant de PO que ça
comme j'étais autour de 196 pendant
l'hiver puis j'ai pas vraiment perdu de
force je n'ai pas gagné mais je n'ai pas
perdu mais tu sais ça c'est parce on
continue quand même en enfire c'est là
justement où est-ce que tu sais ça c'est
le myth de genre ah si tu veux lifter
plus arrête de courir tu peux pas faire
les deux en même temps puis ce qui est
le fun dans le CrossFit c'est oui tu
peux pu on ben on l'a démontré fait puis
cette étude là dans le fond j'ai lu
là-dessus puis cette étude là été basé
sur genre un X nombre de semaines étude
contrôlé machin machin fait la
l'hypothèse la leçon qu'on en tire c'est
sûr c'est semaines là sur ce contexte là
tu sais c'est pas dans un contexte de
vie fait oui tu peux devenir plus rapide
puis améliorer ton cardio et augmenter
ta force et être plus puissant et tout
le reste fait c'est ça qui est
intéressant avec le CrossFit fait c'est
sûr que Y des bases puis des il y a des
choses qu'on veut travailler en off
season versus off season mais de quand
même s'assurer qu'on touche à tout pour
justement être prêt ça c'est c'est
toujours le fait on met rien de côté on
va mettre passer un peu plus de temps
sur certains aspects mais on met jamais
rien de côté mais il y
a-tu il y atu à travers toutes les les
disciplines qu'lobe le CrossFit comme
quand même une qui est plus par exemple
l'altro est-ce que vous PZ passer plus
de temps comme la chose la plus centrale
ou importante ou même pas pas vraiment
ça dépend des personnes tu sais comme
moi j'ai toujours été relativement fort
fait que j'ai pas besoin d'en faire
autant que quelqu'un d'autre me tte la
force ou du du weightlifting ouais puis
là tu vois cette année j'ai concentré
mes efforts sur du cardio pu ça a été
vraiment payant fait tu sa ça dépend qui
tu es puis comment qu'est-ce que tu as
besoin de faire tu sais si quelqu'un a
déjà plein de cardio ben c'est sûr qu'il
va en faire un peu moins puis il va
essayer de faire plus de force plus
d'alté moi je pense que ça c'est plus
dur à faire que d'aller chercher du
cardio around c'est plus facile mais ça
dépend qui tu es puis après ça tu
décides où tu mets ton temps ou tu sais
ça dépend de tes objectifs si on parle
de quelqu'un qui compétitionne pas mon
ben c'est quoi tu veux tu veux prendre
du poid puis être fort tu veuxtu faire
plus comme ça dépend vraiment des
objectifs des gens ouais mais au
niveau au niveau compétitif dans le fond
c'est tout le temps de travailler ses
faiblesses finalement exact ouais fa si
tu es moins bon à course ben je de
courir
moins fort que les autres c'est sû tu
vas perdre des points làit faut que tu
AES chercher le maximum que tu es
capable mais le CrossFit étant le le le
tip of the pyramid c'est le sport dans
la méthodologie de CrossFit c'est quand
même il y a une base ton conditionnement
métabolique sur les 12 tests il y en a
eu un sa force il y en a eu deux autres
qui étaient pesants ok mais le reste ça
teste justement ta capacité cardespir ça
ça c'est ça que ça que ça check fait ça
teste ton VO2 beaucoup là
c'est de la haute intensité fait oui ça
vaut la peine de si c'est une de tes
faiblesses mais même chose ça peut pas
être au détriment des autres ça peut pas
être au détriment de ta capacité
cardioesiratoire qui est la base de tout
le reste c pas capable de respirer
marche pas là ou il y avait quand même
dans dans le l'épreuve le test du 5 kg
il y avait j'ai oublié le nom du de
l'athlète russe qui s'est blessé à
l'avant dernière journée là mais quand
qu'on le mettrait en contract avec toi
qui était comme avec ta strape ta monte
puis qui avait l'air de rester comme en
contrôle de toi-même il y avait lui à
côté qui avait pas de stp pas de Monte
juste comme au feeling pu qui a fini
finalement je pense juste derrière toi
pas loin à bloc là dans dans le dernier
derrière aller on dirait qu'il y avait
là deux philosophies deux philosophies
deux approches du sport est-ce que je me
trompe plus il avait l'air de juste
comme y aller au feeling carrément tu
sais c'est un athlète qui a été prouvé
qui a prouvé dans les dernières années
que sur des mono là fait sur de la
course du bik des trucs de Mme il est
vraiment vraiment bon surprenamment bon
pour un athlète de cette taille là là
parce qu'il est grand il fait 6 pieds
225 230 livres fait sais quand tu
connais quand tu te connais tu es pas
obligé de l'avir ta monde tu sais moi je
l'avais parce que je gardais mon heart
rate en check puis je savais que j'étais
pas obligé d'aller passer une certaine
zone tu sais puis que si je passais
cette zone là c'était une décision que
je prenais qui me coûtait quelque chose
ouais lui il est allé au feeling parce
qu'il est allé au feeling après lui je
pense c'est une position qui
l'intéressait plus que d'autres choses
clairement ça coûté quelque chose là à à
fin ça payait fort tu sais il y en a
d'autres athlètes qui étaient dans dans
dans les qure C premiers tout le long
avec moi que ça le ça le drop solide à
fin puis tu sais c'est c'est ça le
risque que je parle tu sais fait si tu
si tu vas au-delà de tes capacités puis
sur des épreuves de même c'est vraiment
facile d'y aller ben un coup tu as
redliné là tu peux plus revenir là c'est
terminé faut que tu marches tu as pas le
choix fait que c'est c'est un peu ça qui
qui c'est c'est moi c'est pour ça que
j'avais ma monre puis ma strap puis ils
nous ont permis aussi de les utiliser je
sais que dans le passé des fois il nous
disait non pas de monte pour pas avoir
de GPS pour pas qu'on sache la distance
c'est comme je pense c'est en Californie
en 2020 le looup fa ils nous ont fait
faire une loupe quand qu'on arrivé en
bas on le savait pas on pensait que
c'était fini puis ils nous ont renvoyé
en sens inverse
ok fait de oui mais c'est pour ça il
nous avait dit pas de monde parce qu'il
voulait pas qu'on sache la distance
qu'on avait parc couru ah ouais je pense
cétait pour ça mais ça ça c'était
violent comme workout ça cétait pas
drôle mais il voulait Il vou il voulait
pas vous le dire avant ILT jamais dit
mal organisé c la stratégie pas le gros
la grosse surprise c'était ça comme il y
avait ça dans leur poche dans le fond en
arrière de faire un spectacle un peu de
quand les gens vont arriver au finish
line c'est pas le finish line c'est la
moitié de l'event tu revi Debord puis
les premier à être arrivé il ont fait
comme attends tu es sérieux puis tues
vois cour comme ça puis non non il a
fallu qu'il refasse tout FA tu vois la
finish l il reste 200 m
tuintar en sauté ben j'étais 3è puis
j'avais le 4e juste en arrière de moi
fait que j'ai sprinté pour me rendre à
finich pu me dit non TeV moi jeéai cuit
l'ut gars il m' dépassé ça pas pris
longemp c'est débile on dirait c'est
comme c'est quoi le c'est quoi
l'objectif tu sa c'est juste ça dépend
de qui tu es si tu regardes c'était un
show mais si tu le fais c'est ordinaire
pour
test moiiti parce que justement tu à
quelquun qui sa arrive à la fin tu V
ouvrir leses tu vid pu let's go fait
pour unent est-ce que tu dis oui
j'essaie de tester le fitness moitié Mo
messageie c'est forc plus jamais au max
dans n'importe quelle épreuve dans le
fond par que G tout le temps cette carte
qui peuvent tout le temps sortir c'est
je jamais me rendre au
bout voyons appréhensif après de
justement comme à chaque fois c'est on
court 4 points un 5 tu es sûr comme on
est pu tout le monde le dit puis essaie
justement de rassurer tout le monde mais
en même temps le Crosset essaie aussi de
tester ta résilience mental fait pour
certaines personnes sais par exemple lui
il est arrivé il était 3e fallait qu'il
reparte ben l'autre compétiteur en
arrière lui peut se dire ok il m' là je
sais que j'ai toute cette opportunité là
estce que je la prends je la prends pas
je suis ou physiquement là-dedans puis
il y a des athlètes qui ont réussi
surtout du côté féminin à se passer des
gens là qui sont partis d'une 5e à une
3è place ou une 2uxè place parce que
justement des piic de puis comme ça les
a motivé fait sais c'est un 50 50 sur ce
que tu approuves ou tu n'approuves pas
la tactique là mais puis non je pense
pas qu'ils vont
le mais cé mais c'est pour ça aussi
qu'il voulait pas avoir de monde parce
que pour ceux qui en auraient eu ou qui
en avait çaait un petit peu injuste puis
oui là tu aurais pu calculer puis c'est
comme aller chercher plus d'information
faitou ai moi j'aurais été dans qui fait
genre ça peut pas être ça genre une
compétition physique peut pas être ça m
mais je comprends le point de la de la
euh de l'endurance mentale effectivement
on dirait que c'est comme c'est tu la
place mais c'est ça aussi je pense un
des intérêts du Crossfit c'est que il y
a un côté quand même spectacle à ça à la
compétition puis tu sais du point de vue
du public comment les épreuves sont
montées c'est tout le temps excitant à
regarder tu sais c'est tout le temps
facile aussi de de de sais de de voir
qui qui est en avance sur qui de tu sais
on dirait que tout est fait en sorte que
que c'est c'est impressionnant plus que
certains
sport de compétition où justement tout
est
super standardisé en fait toujours
pareil sauf que tu sais regarder
justement un 1500 1500 1500 m de
natation sais pas super excitant comp de
natation c'est c'est un beau sport mais
c'est pas la chose la plus excitante à
regarder versus quand qu'on essaie de
créer un event les 200
son même les 400 m là c'est récemment là
qu' un français un je pensais que le
record
làdedans marchant je pense qu' s'appelle
c'est c'était le dernier record de
Michael philps est tombé cétait quelque
chose ouais oua il y a quand même des
moments incroyables je dire aux
Olympiques en attation il a tout le
temps des histoires c'est impressionnant
quand même mais mais tu sais c'est ça tu
sais rese cross c'est quand même c'est
fait pour pour être aussi AC une
dimension je pense spectacle ça qui r
mais qui r ça le fun pour pour le monde
comme moi quic
çaouis exact si c'est assez bien fait me
puis que c'est le fun à regarder
généralement c'est aussi le fun à faire
pu c'est ça tu sais les organisateurs de
CrossFit c'est une gros job pareil de
faire faut un que tu fasses un test
complet sur sur les 4 jours tu sais fait
faut que ça soit du long du court du
lourd du légeris il faut que tu fasses
un peu de tout faut que ça soit le fun à
regarder puis il faut que ça soit comme
le fun à faire fait que c'est c'est
quand même une grosse job cette année
les games moi j'ai vraiment apprécié la
programmation était était quand même
était était plaisante à faire même pour
les
athlètes plus que d'autres années tu
sais il y a d'autres années où tu finis
les games tu es complètement ruiné
mentalement physiquement pété tu veux
juste dormir pendant 2 semaines de temps
puis tu sais c'était pas tant
intéressant à faire non plus tu es comme
moin c'est moins le fun mais quand que
tout est build comme pour être plaisant
à regarder plaisant à faire ça ça rend
l'expérience vraiment plus intéressante
puis là cétait combien de te GAM ce que
tu faisais cette année 5e tu les 5e tu
es arrivé je pense deux fois 5e ouais
ouais puis tu sais là tu as gagné cette
année est-ce que dans ta
préparation tu sentais que cette année
il y avait quelque chose de différent tu
tu sentais plus en confiance plus en
forme ouais définitivement tu doutais
que tu allais bien performer ben on
shoait pour un podium puis rien de moins
après ça tu sais pour moi le podium
c'est comme un truc flou tu sais TR de 1
je m'en fous un peu tu sais parce que
mon but Ctait juste d'avoir une médaille
c'est ça l'objectif premier c'était
podium puis finalement mais ça allait
tellement bien je comme là c'est c'est
drôle parce que le weekend il a
tellement parti d'une façon genre pour
moi c quand même ordinaire là j'étais
genre même pas dans le top 10 pour la
première journée je pense à la fin de la
première à la fin de la première journée
j'étais pas dans le top 10 ou tout juste
c'était ordinaire mon affaire puis là
vendredi grimpe un peu puis là le leader
il avait plus que 100 points d'avance
vendredi soir j'ai comme bon ben on se
bat pour TR puis de tu sais comme faut
se rendre à TR puis de parce que un on
réussir jamais à le rattraper mais ça
c'est genre d'affaire
Jeff il vocalise un peu ce qui ce qu'il
pense mais c'est pas tu sais comme tu
dit ça mais en même temps c'était
sérieux mais c'était pas sérieux on à
moitié du weekend il restait 6 6 test
comme statistiquement c'est encore
faisable mais la première chose qui a
passé c'tait genre ah c'est
voilà faut tu regardes ça objectivement
tu as une personne qui est déjà s points
d'avance qui te laisse pas tant de
points que ça sur table il a pas laissé
de points sur table pendant moitié des
games tu comme s'il fait la même chose
sur la deuxième moitié même si je finis
premier tout le long puis qu'il finit
deè tout le long j'arrive pas tu sais ça
marchera pas fait que c'est un petit peu
ça moi les calculs que je faisais dans
ma tête je comme bon ben gar ben moi il
faut que je continue à pousser parce que
là sinon on finira pas TR puis de non
plus tu sais fait que on allait pour TR
puis de puis finalement ben moi j'ai
grimpé grimpé grimpé grimpé jusqu'à fin
fait tu sais ça a été ça a été comme un
un parcours plaisant parce que tu tu
pars un petit peu derrière puis tu finis
devant ça fait plus intéressant que
partir devant puis finir derrière M
ouais on m'a souvent dit que puis moi je
l'ai jamais expérimenté pour moiême j'ai
fait quatre marathons dans ma vie puis
on m'a souvent dit que c'était plus le
fun dépasser le monde à fin que se faire
dépasser à fin moi je l'ai jamais
vraiment su
mais effectivement qu'apparemment que ça
doit être plus fun de faire ça dans ce
sens là là ouais parce que c'est souvent
ben dans les deux cas c'est la même
chose ça veut dire qu'à fin tu es plus
fatigué tu es tu es mentalement c'est ça
te fait chier un peu d'être là parce que
ça va pas bien puis là tu te fais
dépasser en plus c'est comme tu sais ça
s'en pile puis mentalement c'est dur à
prendre h c'est clair puis c'est ça do
être d'autant plus
motivant quand tu sais tu sais parce que
là une des dernières épreuves je pense
c'était vraiment la la force là fa que
le le Snatch puis le je sais pas ouais
c'est ça puis ça ça s'envenait puis tu
devais savoir que là tu tu avais tu
avais des bonnes cartouches encore là tu
sais je pense c'est là que tu as pris
lead CTA samedi soir fa moi samedi
c'était la course après ça on avait le
petit
sprint avec le ramur lesp les boîes les
deux intervalles puis le soir céit le
LIF le lift j'ai toujours vraiment
confiance dans mes lifts sauf cette
annéeou j'ai eu des petits bobos pendant
l'année qui m'ont pas permis de faire de
clean and jerk P tout comme je nai pas
fait je pense j'en ai pas fait de l'été
puis la fois que je naai fait je me suis
refaite mal fait que j'ai arrêté d'en
faire fait quand que quand ouais quand c
workout là il é annoncé j'éis comme ah
merde mais le format ouais en plus du
format parce on avait juste deux essais
c'est deux essais 20 secondes deux
essais tu as 20 secondes pour le lever
puis après ça il y a le le clean and Jer
même choseou tu accumulais le meilleur
des deux essais exact le total des
deuxis tu buildes ou tu choisis un poid
puis choisis un poid puis tu Rouvres
tuas 20 il il nous permettait de faire
pas mal ce qu'on voulait mais en 20
secondes tu as pas le temps là tu un ESS
tu as un essai au Snatch tu en as
peut-être deux parce que c'est moins
lourd puis tu peux comme te replacer
puis la règle cétait si ta bord a
décollé du sol avant comme à 19 si tu
finis le Liv c'était good sa fait que tu
avais deux essais mais au cleananger
quand tu es rendu en haut de 300 Mons
320 330 livr tu as pas deux essais là
parce qu'il faut que tu fasses le clean
là tu attends un peu tu fais ton jerk
bah tu es ta le lift en soi il prend 7
secondes tu as pas le temps là de te
remettre dedans puis comment tu sa parce
que tu sais ça tu connais évidemment ton
max là tu sais de tu connais tes
capacités flou étné que tu pas fait une
foisis mon max de cleananger qui date de
2019 ben mes deux max il datent de 2019
j'ai jamais refait plus lourd que que ça
avec les années ok mais comment dans une
comment dans une compétition tu
détermines comment comment tu liftes
comment tu mets bah là tu veux avec ce
format là on avait deux les fait moi ce
que j'ai décidé de faire c'est de faire
le premier comme quelque chose de assez
solide mais conservateur que tu sais que
tu vas réuss être sûr de mettre ça carte
c'est ça ça prend un Liv si tu as zé tu
es dans merde ça c'est sûr fait moi j'ai
ouvert mon Snatch à
276 ce qui est un un livre relativement
lourd mais vraiment faisable aussitôt
que je tombe à 280 et plus c'est là où
pour moi ça commence à être
compliqué mais écoute ça filet je sais
même pas comment ça se faisait que ça
filait goûte de même mais le squat filit
écurant j'ai réussi
282 2 ou TR 2 comment après c'est ça
comment après ton premier après ton
premier tu fais genre ok là je
l'aiéclairé easy on va aller à
282 bah cétait 5 livres c'était 5 livres
de plus 5 ou 6 livres de plus euh moi je
voulais faire
285 mais ben j'avais une jaosette avec
un des mon training partner qui qui
était là pour
regarder il me donnait des chiresis
parce que lui il s'ent trraîe avec moi
fait qu'il connaitt mes chiffs aussi là
puis il voit aussi tout ce que tout le
monde fait fait tu sais comme moi
j'étais dans le dernier j'étais
l'avant-dernier à faire mon lift fait
pendant le temps que je faisais mon lift
ou que je me préparais à le faire je
voyais pas les autres qu'est-ce qu'il
allait mettre sur leur deuxème euh essai
mais lui il voyait fait que là aôt quand
moi je finissais je regardais d'St il y
avait un petit tableau blanc pu là il
marquait un chiffre là j'étais comme ah
ok ouais c'est bon fait que là j'ai j'ai
fait mon deuxième Snatch puis c'est au
Clean and jerk où moi j'ai pris un petit
peu plus grand risque euh parce que
justement j'avais pas fait un cleanger
comme une chance sur de j'ai unou qui je
sais pas tr'est qui va arriver puis
finalement comme du BE ça s'est
passé j'étais aussi techniquement 16
lives en dessus de mon 1 fait que
j'avais de la
mar un RM là mais techniquement mon à
dub j'avais fait 376
ou
360 combien à 385 ouais mais c'est juste
le J c'est juste le J ouais je sais
ouais j'avis un peu quand même 16 livres
de d'un pibi de qui date de 3 ans quand
on n pas fait depuis des mois c'est
quand même quand même risquéouais ouais
cétait c'était ça c'est je vois-tu la
voir c'était la première question qui
que je me posais ça si je le l c'est
qu'est-ce que ça va me coûter sais je v
me faire mal encore comme la dernière
fois pu la dernière fois je m'étais fait
mal a pas mal plus léger que ça oua mais
mal les épreuves d'après là c'est ouais
c'est on l'a vu avec avec Roman ce que
ça fait tu sais c'est un petit peu
compliqué là quand même ouais oh lui lui
il s'est pété il y aurait probablement
tu l'aurais probablement battu comm les
à faaires à l'aide de toute façon ben on
le saura jamais hein tu sais parce que
c'est c'est vous aviez deux trajectoires
quand même là dans comme le le le
momentum de GAM oui moi moi
personnellement je pense que les dans
les deux derniers workout il y en avait
un pour moi puis un pour lui c'est juste
qui qui aurait fait mieux que l'autre
sais ça ça ça c'était une question de
points là après le après le 10è event
j'avais deux points sur lui puis tu sais
quand quand quand qu'on en parlait j'éis
comme ben tu sais si j'ai si j'ai
rattrapé 100 points en une journée ben
techniquement il pourrait m'en mettre 60
sur deux events sa ça se fait c'est pas
impossible comme moi j'aurais pu en
mettre 60 aussi sur les deux derniers
events fait tu sais les commentaires sur
les internets tout oh lui aurait gagner
on le saura jamais fait moi dans ma tête
les games s'arrêtent à éement 10 mais
j'avais deux points d'avance les games
sont
aussi toutes les tests c'est au maximum
de ses capacités je veux dire c'est des
des blessures ça fait partie de tout je
par au football
souvent puis je sais pas pourquoi je
fais référence au football mais quand il
y a M un corps arrière qui se blesse
puis que mond si c'était pas blessé
téquipe aurait gagné puis la défensive
d' fait comme moi mais c'est nous autres
qui l'ont sorti de la game là tu sais
c'est n autres qui sont se rendu jusqu'à
lui pour le blesser sais pour le frapper
puis c'est blessé en se frappant fait
par la
game monde là jeux dire non exactement
exactement rend la fin ça fait partie de
de l'épreuve dans par çaêt le fun
d'avoir une bataille égale jusqu'à la
fin moi moi j'étais écoute j'étais fire
up là j'étais prêt là moi j'étais prêt à
me battre jusqu'à la finux battre tout
le monde dans leur meilleur dans puis là
tu sais ça comme viré à genre ben c'est
sûr que tu gagnes de toute façon puis
c'est ça a été dur de de pour moi rester
comme focus mentalement tu sais comme je
voulais me donner mais là il y avait
comme plus de raison de me donner j'ai
juste comme fait les workout à la fin fa
c'est comme un peu bizarre ça l' terminé
d'une façon bizarre mais tu aur aimé ça
gagner sur la le dernier sprint final
toucher comme hier ben un peu comme
après l'événement 10 comme le feeling
d'avoir gagné les games je pense c'est
c'est à ce momentl que je l'ai vécu puis
tu sais c'était vraiment c'est c'est
pour ça que moi je dis techniquement
mais mes Games se sont arrêtés à
l'événement 10 puis je pense que c'est
fair de dire ça tu sais je dire oui les
blessures ça fait partie de la game mais
si tu enlèves la blessure Ben éement 10
ça s terminé là puis c'était le c'était
le même classement là il y avait rien
qui change exact exact comment est-ce
que ta vie a changé depuis ça
ben ouais c'est ça je me fais clonner
des
fois ou c'est très drôle euh je me su
faite reconnaître ouais je me su faite
reconnaître une coupe de fois dans rue
ben surtout sais dans les première
semaine j'ai passé dans la presse j'ai
passé aux nouvelles puis là tu sais les
gens ils regardent pu là je pense qu'on
est quand même assez facile à
reconnaître aussi sur la rue on vous
croise dans rue mettons on doute vous
êtes qui si on vous déjà vu là on vous
reconnait là es dans un rayon d'un km
d'un gym de CrossFit
çaug tellement que c'est pas mal
partoutor où mais sinon pour le reste il
y a pas grandchose qui a changé tu sais
je je suis retourné à la maison puis je
retourne à l'entraînement puis là tu
sais c'est juste mon mindset change un
petit peu parce que là on chas plus un
podium on Chase un autre un autre 1 tu
sais puis il y a des compétitions off
season j'ai une compétition dans 2 mois
puis on se prépare pour ça puis on essae
on va essayer de gagner là aussi c'est
ça parce que les Games c'est une fois
par année puis comment on reste motivé
quand qu'il y a un gros événement de
même par année ben il y en a d'autres
plus gros événements dans l'année tu sa
comme là moi je fais le rogue
Invitational au mois de fin fin octobre
dernier weekend d'octobre c'est une
grosse compétition il invite le top 15
des games fait techniquement c'est un
deuxième game puis il se gardent un 5
spot en qualification fait qu' y a
d'autres gens qui étaient pas au Games
ou sont forts qui se qualifi c'est ça
les autres se rendent ils se rendent
avec nous autres puis c'est souvent des
du calibre Games anyway qui font qui
réussissent à se rendre fait ça c'est
quand même une grosse puis il y en a une
couple dans l'année fait qu'il y a rogue
en octobre il y a Dubaï en décembre il y
a water pulsa à Miami en janvier puis
les trois comme toutes les Top 40 il se
divisent un petit peu sur les trois tu
sais fait que ça ça fait des quand même
grosse compétition off season moi je
choisis d'en faire juste une parce que
une c'est suffisant pour moi puis après
ça je tombe en vrai off season fait
novembre décembre janvier février moi je
reste tranquille à maison je fais toutes
mon zone 2 puis mes petits cardio puis
c'est là où genre le gros du travail
pour l'année se passe pour être prête
pour l'été puis là à l'été c'est là où
l'intensité devient un petit peu genre
euh épeurante si on veut puis après ça
tu vas au Games fait il faut vraiment
que tu fasses les bonnes courbes au
travail de l'année parce que si tu
restes sur un high toute l'année c'est
sûr tu es pas capable de rester motivé
pour plus que 2 ans tu vas tu vas faire
une petite dépresse puis tu vas skiper
une année fait quand c'est temps de
prendre off off season c'est vraiment
important de le faire h un an moi je
trouve ça pas super si on se compare aux
Olympiques 4 ans c'est ça do être
tellement
long puis c'est c'est ça fait un an
c'est c'est ça ça permet d'avoir comme
du bon on du bon off de repéartir de de
resetter tes objectifs de de faire tout
ce travail là de de fond dans le fond
puis fait moi je trouve que c'est un
time frame intéressant puis est-ce que
la carrière d'athlète
professionnel c'est quelque chose qui se
planifie sur le long terme Mons là ton
développement d'athlète là est-ce que
vous pensez dans vos planification à
comme ok où est-ce qu'on veut être dans
2 ans dans 4 ans est-ce qu'on veut
encore faire ça dans 6 ans Mons c'est
comment vous voyez ça ben ça dépend de
mon corps honnêtement tu sais là moi
j'ai 29 puis je me tombe pas dans je
suis dans les vieux tu sais c'est plate
à dire mais un ge P CrossFit tu sais 27
278 pour les gars peut-être entre 25
puis 30 notons ok la f est quand même
relativement grande ouais tu sais comme
G Justin il a gagé quand même c'est ça
le problème fait Justin il a gagné 22 pu
23 ou 23 24 24 était quand même
relativement jeune mais il a commencé à
faire du Crossfit à genre 8 ans sais moi
j'ai commencé j'avais 20 ans là j'étais
quand même plus vieux fait on a on a le
même nombre d'entraînement voir même lui
en a plus fait moi ça m'a pris plus
longtemps me rendre j'ai 29 c'est le
plus vieux cette année qui
compétitionnait c'était P il y a 33 puis
a fini 3 il a fini
2è sur le podium avec moi tu sais je nai
tu pour M je n pour 4 ans encore tu sais
si lui il est là à 33 je me rendre à 33
ça dépend vraiment de si je me blesse ou
non c'est ça est-ce que c'est plus la
pensée prévention ben blessure qui
pourrait er la carrière ou diminution
des capacités parce que j'ai comme
l'impression que 33 tu es encore capable
de de maintenir mettons minimum
maintenir ce que tu es là ça je pense ça
commence à être un réel challenge parce
que là tu as 33 puis tu te bas contre
des 21 22 qui ont 10 ans de moins que
toi là c'est tu sais là la récupération
à rentrer en ligne de compte
sérieusement parce que si tu manques ta
chot c'est s tu tes pas tu sais après ça
dépend des blessures il y en a des
blessures où tu sais comme wi George
c'est déchiré la bromme dans un épaule
ça pris un an il est revenu puis est
revenu top shape tu sais c'est ça dépend
c'est quoi la blessure ça dépend après
si la blessure mentalement à te sort du
de la compétition là tu as juste plus
envie tu sais le monde compétitif c'est
c'est tof si tu arrêtes moi je je sais
personnellement moi si j'arrête je Seris
pas qu' de revenir comme faut que tu
sois commit à 100 % faut que tu sois in
au complet là tu peux pas juste le faire
à moitié fait que c'est tant qu'à être
dedans on va le toffer le plus longtemps
qu'on est capable
J je vais pas pousser plus loin ça je
vais Marr je pas pous plus loin c'est S
puis les
blessures de ce que moi je comprends du
Crossfit c'est quelque chose qui est
quand même fréquent mais tout alète
professionnel va avoir des
blessures
impor des SPS de contact quand même qui
peut expliquer la plart oui
al à pied mais ouais c'est mais c'est ça
effec même on regarde toutes les
Olympiens là ces gens-là sont suivis par
des équipes de physio d'ostéo de Kiro de
Masso la récupération est tellement
importante parce que tu utilises ton
corps pour ça c'est des heures et des
heures c'est ton cerveau les gens vont
travailler 9 à 5 mais tu utilises ton
cerveau de 9 à 5 plus tu rend ta maison
tu continues d'utiliser ton cerveau mais
on voit pas ce que ça fait j'utilise un
muscle à répétition tu vas voir ce que
ça fait sur
ou untit peu ça a des blessures que ça
va juste puis si on parle just des
professionsons plus physique là des gens
dans la construction des gens qui
travaillent avec leur corps c'est la
même chose je dire on parle de blessures
d'usure on on peut jouer sur les mots
mais c'est un petit peu normal où est-ce
qu'il y en est c'est quelqu'un qui
utilise son corps pour gagner sa vie
c'est pas moi qui s'entraîne du haut de
mon heure quatre fois par semaine c'est
comme je peux quand même développer quel
chose parce que oui à sur entraîner ou à
surutiliser quelque chose c'est des
tendinites c'est ça se fait mais sinon
c'est juste c'est quelque chose qui est
présent autant pour quelqu'un qui
utilise son corps qu'on pourit dire des
burnout pour les gens qui font du fait
fait c'est un petit peu ça là plus les
blessures les plus répandues me t c'est
des tendinites tu sais moi je m'en
souviens la première fois je m'étais
fait une tendinite à co aller voir le le
physio puis là le physio était comme oh
my god ton C des pét il reviendra jamais
et ça m'avait
moi pour moi je fini des tinit j'en ai
fait une douzaine depuis ce tempsl si
c'est pas plus tendinit c'est rien comme
c'est vraiment pas grave là c'est de
l'inflammation puis ça part pourquoi ça
arrive parce que mon genou il a plié
25000 fois dans de dernier mois tu sais
c'est sûr qu'il va avoir de
l'inflammation fait tu sais c'est juste
un petit peu puis ça c'est là où la
programmation ça rentre en en ligne de
compte c'est genre ben tu sais si tu as
squaté trop ben on va squatter moins on
va dliifter plus puis là c'est comme ça
je pense qu'on on est capable d'éviter
les blessures au maximum quand je fais
mon off season j'ai beaucoup de courses
je suis un gars pisant pour faire autant
de volume ben faut que je fasse
attention faut je fasse les faut le
faire progressivement faut je m'assure
que je fasse mes warm up comme il faut
puis tout ça tu sais c'est fait tu sais
c'est c'est c'est c'est le mot blessure
c'est comme pe mais il devrait pas tu
sais puis tu regardes justement tennis
elbow golfers elbow c'est nommé pour
monde mais c'est sûr que si tu vas jouer
au golf trois fois par semaine pendant
toute l'été puis tu fais rien l'hiver
ben ton premier mois tu vas te faire une
tendinite tu sais comme fait le mot
blessure est très épeurant mais dans le
fond c'est c'est une usur qui est
potentiellement normal basé sur le
volume que tu mets justement à faire une
action qui est répétitive mais tu sais
après si tu parles de blessures genre tu
sa comme Willy qui sont la bromme il a
complètement déchiré puis est allé tu il
a dû se faire opérer ben ça c'est un
puis après ça il y en a eu peut-être un
autre depuis ce tempsl tu sais c'est pas
genre fréquent mon euh comme dans le
strongman où il se déch les deux quad
complètement là tu sais ça ça l'arrive
pas tant que ça dans le monde du
Crossfit c'est plus des tendinit puis
des petits bobos il c'était là qui vont
t'empêcher de t'entraîner fait que là ça
ça l'impacte tes performances ça c'est
sûr mais c'est pas des trucs super
graves puis de de juste de comment vous
avez répondu à ma question j'imagine que
ça c'est quelque chose qui vous est
demandé souvent parce que clairement tu
sais c'était j'ai dit le mot blessure
puis je vous ai vu tout de suite vous
crispez j'imagine que parce que la
raison pour laquelle la raison pour
laquelle je j'ai posé la question c'est
parce que moi dans ma tête tu sais à
mettons juste un clean and jerk là moi
je me vois faire ce mouvement là le
faire un peu tout croch puis me
décalisser l'épaule m tu sais ça va
revenir éventuellement puis c'est un peu
pour ça je pose la question mais à la
façon avec laquelle vous avez répondu
j'imagine c'est quelque chose qu'on
qu'on lance souvent au CrossFit ben
c'est quelque chose qui do un c'est
comme CrossFit ég blessure ouais mais
attends là on va prendre le mot blessure
on de côté puis on va c'est quoi une
blessure tu sais parce que tout le monde
pense justement que tu vas t'arracher un
épaule ben un si tu le fais comme il
faut tu vas pas t'arracher un épaule tu
es pas seosé ça te prend un bon coach
une personne qui te le Monte tu sais
puis l'altérose ça prend du temps à
prendre faut que tu puiss ça il y a du
monde qui ne font que chose faut que tu
prennes le temps de l'apprendre si tu
prends le temps de l'apprendre tu vas
pas te faire mal comme une progression
par comme la course tu peux pas aller
courir 50 km demain matin non non faut
que tu faut que tu fasses les
progressions nécessaires
c'est ça le gros problème c'est qu'il
faut que les gens prennent le temps
quand tu commences à faire du Crossfit
c'est prends la première année pour
aller douo c'est correct sais tu vas
quand même être plus en santé puis tu
vas pas te faire mal c'est si tu pars Z0
à 100 d'une chot là ben là oui ton
risque de blessure parce que c'est le
fun tu sais même chose quelqu'un qui
commence à courir puis il P son R de
course puis aime ça être à l'extérieur
tout ça ah mais je le faisais deux fois
là je vais le faire trois fois pu moment
ça devient juste comme un petit peu trop
mais les mots ont deimportance puis oui
tu sais comme justement c'est sa
première fois que tu Allis voir le
physio tu sais puis moi j'étudi en
physiothérapie j'ai mon diplôme de trp
faut que tu fasses attention à ce que tu
dis aux gens puis surtout à qui tu
parles c'est quelqu'un qui voulait en
faire une carrière puis là tu dis qu'il
y a une tendinite faut qu'il prenne faut
qu'il arrête pu tout tu fais peur à
cette personne là puis c'est pas
l'intention qu'il y avait derrière tu as
besoin du repos on va faire de la fysion
on va faire de la rehab la prhab faut
faut regagner justement la force de ce
tissu là mais le mot blessure est un
petit peu comme lancé à droite puis à
gauche puis les gens justement c'est un
alète professionnel il s'est habitué on
est good mais quelqu'un tu sais toi vous
vous venez au gym làble mon épaule me
dérange puis là tu V voir un physio ah
tuas une blessure à l'épaule faut que
tuarrêes pendant 2 semaines c'est sûr
que ça te fait peur pu c'est pas le but
c'est on comprend que tu as besoin de
repos qu'on a besoin de faire des
exercices c'est où devent le problème et
tout mais si dit le physio cette personn
là prend pas le temps de poser les
questions c'est quoi tu veux est-ce que
tu veux qu'on so tu veux tu Contin à
faire de la course à pied mais je te
recommande d'aller va marcher ou fais
moins de volume
on est toutes pressé dans nos jobs
est-ce qu'on prend le temps de bien
faire les choses de bien communiquer de
bien expliquer fait puis moi je
travaille plus avec justement sais je
coach je deal avec avec ça fait oui moi
c'est quelque chose qui va me chercher
vraiment loin parce que tout le monde
veut être en forme tout le monde essaie
de bien faire les choses là tu te rends
compes ah mais j'ai une blessure j'ai du
mal le faire toi tu te sens mal c'est
c'est c'est c'est ça qui est plate fait
moi je m'assuré que gen pas que c'est
pas grave mais il y a moyen de dealer
avec la situation puis de continuer à
idéalement faire ce que tu aimes puis
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'organiser
puis m'assurer que tu gardes tes
habitudes parce que justement c'est ça
qui est difficile à bâtir puis aller de
fil en éguille que ce soit une personne
justement qui s'entraîne par plaisir par
santé que ce soit même un athlète
professionnel que genre c'est aussi hent
pour les autres de se faire de se faire
dire qu'ils sont
blessés ça c'est drôle quand en a des
fois ils viennent au gym de nos membres
là oh j'is allé au physio je une tendin
au poignet je comme ah ok bon c'est
correct ça va tu tu vas survivre c'est
rien là il me regarde avec des gros yeux
des tendinites j'en ai partout moi comme
ça va là tu vas survivre là fais juste
slquer un peu dessus puis genre fais pas
fais pas des niaiseries puis utilise l'
bras un peu plus là tu sais comme prends
un dumbelle au lieu de prendre une
barbelle sais c'est tout c'est comme ah
ouais ah c'est pas si que ça ben non
c'est pas si que ça tu sais c'est juste
genre tuas un peu d'inflammation tu
laisses tranquille un peu puis ça
revient tu sais c'est juste de comme
diminuer un peu genre le le stress qui
est lié à genre le mot blessure c'est
moi ça je me c'est peut-être pour ça que
j'ai réagi de la façon c'est la première
fois que je me l'ai fait dire moi
c'était tout était
fini c'est pas fini c'est pas si grave
comme on va survivre c'est correct ouais
mais y a quand même tu sais moi je dire
j'en ai j'en fait du cross j'en fait
quand même depuis longtemps pour le
plaisir puis pour la santé vraiment pas
en mode performance quoi que ce soit tu
sais puis la plupart je veux dire de le
reste de mon de ma vie est est pas je
dir pas dans le monde est pas centré sur
le CrossFit puis les gens que je
fréquente font pas du Crossfit puis puis
des fois quand je dis le mot CrossFit
ben là c'est comme si il y a quand même
certaines idées préconçues qui vient
avec ça de ah et vous faites des
exercices le plus vite possible genre
lourd un peu sis un peu tout croche tu
sais puis là c'est comme bah mon
expérience c'est pas exactement ça mais
tu sais puis gen c'estis pas tu sais euh
sais le fameux numéro du Crossfit là de
l'humoriste sement déjà vu ça passer là
comment SIM mon gouche en tout cas
googerez ça non mais tu sais je sais pas
tu sais il y a comme des fois un genre
de
CrossFit c'est comme tu vas là puis tu
te fais juste comme faire complètement
casser puis là tu retournes chez vous
puis puis tu peux plus bouger pendant
une semaine tu sais genre puis des fois
c'est le parce que des fois c'est F de
se pousser mais mais dans le sens que tu
sais des fois le le quand je dis je fais
du Crossfit genre c'est comme si la
perception puis moi mon expérience de ce
que c'est il y a quand même une
distorsionou ben il y a une historique
aussi dans qui qui faisait du Crosset en
2010 puis comment qu'on le fait faisait
puis qui qui en a fait en 2015 puis qui
en fait en 2020 puis ça c'est la même
chose dans plusieurs sports pu il y a
une évolution c'est just que là c'est
jeune comme sport encore M la courbe
d'évolution est pas mal plus drastique
que mettons la course à pied qu'on cours
depuis qu'on existe là en fait je pense
mais fait il y a un petit peu de ça
aussi il y a des perceptions qui étaient
là en 2010 2015 qui ne sont plus les
mêmes c'est les coach maisalem il ont 10
ans et plus d'expérience il y avait pas
dans le temps puis ça c'est plate c'est
juste la profession qui doit se
professionnaliser puis devenir meilleur
ça reste un sport d'intensité mais tu
sais juste je ramène tout le temps un
petit peu à d'autres sport j'ai pris
trois cours de snowboard dans ma vie ça
m'empêche pas aller faire du snowboard
fait qu'est-ce qui t'empêcheraener faire
du Crossfit tu vas peut-être bouger un
peu croch tu V m'assurer que c'est
sécuritaire mais qu'est-ce qui
t'empêcherait de venir le faire tu sais
il y a un petit peu cette perception là
tu sais justement quand je dois faire du
ski du snow en hiver ben je dois pas
avoir de l'aircurente pour quelqu'un qui
en fait tu sais mais ça l'empêche pas
que je peux prendre plaisir puis je peux
participer puis je peux le faire mais
c'est pas tout le monde qui va faire du
ski c'est pas tout le monde qui voit
cette expérience-là tandis que les gyms
B idéalement il y a plus de gens qui ont
eu accès qui qui vont voir qu'
connaissent quelqu'un maintenant qui en
a fait fait tu sa il y a un petit peu
cette perception làà de non je m'attends
pas à ce que tu bouges parfaitement si
tu restes avec moi pendant 5 ans on va y
arriver mais c'est pas en 3 mois 6 mois
un an que justement sur des disciplines
olympiques sur la quantité de mouvements
qu'on fait sur aller chercher le
résultat qui demande une certaine forme
d'intensité puis d'exposure là c'est
comme je te demande pas d'aller à la t
la lumière mais je vais te demander
squat
bouge parce que c'est ça qui va
justement te donner un peu
d'hypertrophie qui va améliorer ton
cardio comme c'est comme ça qu'on va
chercher des résultats fait il y a un
petit peu de ça aussi h euh je sais
qu'il y avait eu une genre de pas une
polémique
mais une une situation entourant
l'utilisation du mot CrossFit doné
CrossFit c'est une une compagnie dans le
fond puis l'utilisation du mot CrossFit
versus entraînement fonctionnel je pense
qui s'appelle
euh j'allais vous demander où vous vous
situez par rapport à ça c'est pas
vraiment ça ma question mais qu'est-ce
qu'on c'est quoi le débatalement ouais
c'est ça mais comment on on on je pense
que c'était le monde utilisait le mot
CrossFit pour parler de l'entraînement
fonctionnel mais que là CrossFit ont
comme fait e vous avez plus le droit
d'utiliser ce terme là tu pourrais pas
avoir un signe McDo puis pas être un
McDo fait ce que CrossFit essayait puis
tu sais c'est un trademark puis moi je
fais une affiliation pour être capable
de dire que j'utilise la méthodologie
CrossFit dans mon gym ça pu c'était plus
ça c'est on peut tous faire de
l'entraînement fonctionnel mais si je
veux vendre que je fais du Crossfit
comme si je veux vendre un ben il faut
que je m'ouvre un McDo fait CIT plus ça
fait que si justement dans la promotion
dans ce que les gens disent sur les Méos
sociaux ton site web peu importe si tu
veux dire que tu fais du Crossfit ben il
faut que tu sois affilié faut que tu
faut que tu le payes parce que oui il y
on trademark CrossFit puis les avantages
de pouvoir dire que tu fais du Crossfit
c'est juste que c'est plus facile à
expliquer aux gens m les gens les gens
il a comme une réflexion de Come ok
CrossFit ont déjà fait toute leur
marketing autour de ça fait quand tu
marques CrossFit ça les gens sont plus
au courant de Ben idéalement oui je
pense qu'on a encore la misère à
verbaliser qu'est-ce que le CrossFit
même si techniquement pas super
compliqué mais se l' tu sais mais c'est
juste justement il y a une méthodologie
derrière puis c'est la même chose que je
te dis que je mange un wer ou un Big Mac
tu sais où est-ce que tu t'en vas puis
tu sais ce que j'ai mangé tandis que si
on dit qu'on fait de l'entraînement
fonctionnel ben on va tout squatter mais
on va pas tout squat sous intensité
parce que le CrossFit a par exemple cet
aspect d'intensité là ou est-ce que je
vais te demander d'aller un peu plus
vite fait c'est un petit peu ça c'est
que oui il devrait avoir des des
références derrière ce motl que
justement si on commence à l'utiliser
sans vraiment définir ce que c'est puis
CrossFit a pris le temps de définir ce
qui était le cross je mange un je mange
pas un wer je pas chez AW puis je suis
pas chez Wendy comme fait que c'est un
petit peu ça puis justement parce que
ils prennent le temps de définir ce que
c'est mais si tu veux faire partie de la
gagne ton affiliation sinon dis que tu
fais de l'entraînement fonctionnel mais
tu peux pas faire les deux mais après tu
sa je pense que c'est dire que tu fais
de l'entraînement fonctionnel c'est
encore plus vague que du Crossfit tu sa
comme si ad mettons tu vas dans un gym
de CrossFit je pense que c'est tu peux
t'attendre à genre x on va faire X à peu
près si on va faire de l'entraînement
fonctionnel ça peut-être vraiment
n'importe quoi là comme c'est quoi de
l'entraînement qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire par entraînement fonctionnel ça va
être on va faire juste des tabat est-ce
qu'on va faire comme un circuit est-ce
qu' on va sais comme on sait vraiment
pas à quoi s'attendre puis je pense que
chaque gym ou place de fitis va comme
faire de l'entraînement fonctionnel à
leur SAU si on veut fait c'est moi c'est
de même je le vois tu sais comme si tu
vas dans un gym de CrossFit tu sais que
tu vas lever des Bordes tu sais que tu
vas les lever l'eau tu vas les lever
lesger tu sais que tu vas faire de la
gymnastique comme dans mon cas je
m'attendrais à courir ou faire une
certaine forme de cardio mais si tu vas
faire l'entraînement fonctionnel c'est
quoi qu'on va faire comme faut que tu
alles pour voir genre c'est c'est quoi
puis après ça tu peux aller dans un
autre gym faire l'entraînement fonction
ça va être complètement différent ça va
être un circuit de bicep trcep
extenstion tu es comme ok mais c'est pas
vraiment à ce que je m'attendais fait
que je pense c'est plus vague de dire
que tu fais de l'entraînement
fonctionnel ça met des cordes dans le
fond puis ça permet de savoir dans quoi
on s'embarque un petit peu justement si
tu veux faire un cours de zumbao tu peux
aller un petit peu n'importe où chaque
cours va avoir sa savoir mais tu sais
que tu fais du Zumba quand tu vas dans
un gym CrossFit il y a certaines
attendes comme que Jeff disait qui sont
pas nécessairement là dans entraînement
fonctionnel puis c'est pas c'est pas une
question de bon ou mauvais ou tu devrais
le faire ou devrais pas le faire c'est
juste une question de les points de
référence sont pas les mêmes fait est-ce
que tu vas aimer ce type là même chose
dans le yoga tu dis V faire un cours de
yoga tu fais quel genre de yoga il y en
a plein fait que oui tu peux avoir un un
un marqueur après pour dire mais je fais
ce type de yoga là ok cool ça va m'aider
à savoir justement ce que tu fais fait
c'est un petit peu plus ça comme le
cross c'est vraiment les les gens
surtout maintenant avec le temps on on
on on a une attente envers ce qu'on ce
qu'on va faire h je comprends puis
comment est-ce que
on c'est quoi le pitch de vendre du
Crossfit mon pour quelqu'un qui qui voit
metton qui qui voit ça a l'air le fun
les les CrossFit GAM ça a l'air complet
ça a l'air d'un sport le fun comment
est-ce qu'on vend ça aux gens comment
est-ce qu'on amène les gens dans gym
pour qu' c'est quoi les les avantages
puis c'est quoi qu'on trouve le fun
mettons pour quelqu'un qui veut pas
nécessement devenir athlète pro là euh
moi je pense de la façon que je le vends
c'est c'est vraiment simple c'est 60
minutes tu rentres tu fais ce qui est
marqué sur le tableau il y a quelqu'un
qui te dit quoi faire puis tu t'en vas
ouais c'est super c'est génial comme tu
rentres il y a quelqu'un qui s'occupe de
toi puis tu sors puis c'est 60 minutes
puis tu sais nous autres on est comme on
a beaucoup de monde de downtwn on a
beaucoup de jeunes professionnels le
temps c'est important comme tu sais que
tu rentres pour 60 minutes puis tu sais
que tu vas avoir un bon workout il y a
de la diversité sur la semaine tu peux
tomber sur un evid tu peux tomber sur un
un cardio d comme ça c'est le fun si tu
es le genre de personne qui aime les
surprises regarde pas c'est quoi la Prue
la veille puis genre ça c'est vraiment
coolis je pense pour moi c'est un peu se
pit de vente c'est pas nécessairement
axé sur la méthodologie ou le mot
CrossFit ou les movvements que tu vas
faire comme pour moi ça c'est pas
important parce que je pense que le but
c'est que tu trouves ça le fun que ça
soit time efficient puis pas compliqué
sais moi je me mets dans la peau des
gens là comme tu as travaill toute la
journée tu as potentiellement des
enfants t'occuper whatever comme c'est 1
heure où est-ce que tu peux juste genre
switch à OFF puis quelqu'un dit fais ça
fais ça mets-toi là puis fais ça puis 3
Go 15 minutes on suit tu t'en
vas l'avantage principal que j'ai trouvé
tu sais à faire du Crossfit parce que tu
sais on faitannotation ensemble moi j'ai
arrêté à 16 ans après secondaire puis
après ça pendant longtemps je me suis
entraîné par moi-même mais je trouve que
trouvver la motivation pour t'entraîner
par to même décider bon aujourd'hui je
fais quoi je ve courir je au Gy je fais
ça juste tu sais juste de que ça ça ça
ça ça vienne de l'intérieur plutôt que
juste dire bon j'ai booké ma session à
8h demain fait que là je vois y aller
parce qu' est booké puis là tu arrives
là tu te fais dire quoi faire pose pas
de question puis même si ça ça te tente
pas on dirait que mett même si pas un
workout que que je me serais écrit
moi-même parce qu'il des affaires
là-dedans qui qui me plat moins comme
mouvement mais les qui comme tu pas ch
tu le fais plus c'est important ça c'est
tellement important d'avoir quelqu'un
qui dit de faire des affaires que tu
aimes pas faire ah oui c'est numéro ça
tes les jours
c'est
quoi des fois je vais au gym par
moi-même je fais juste comme genre une
application qui génère des des W mettons
puis là je suis comme oh non pas lui oh
non pas oui faut que tu prennes une
décision de plus puis honnêtement moi
mon un dépit devant qu'est-ce que tu
recherches c'est c'est vraiment là parce
que le CrossFit peut t'amener peux avoir
beaucoup de réponses tu veux de la
constance tu tu vas être dans un
environnement avec d'autres gens ça va
te pousser même si ça te tente pas tuas
plus besoin de d'être motivé à venir
faut juste que tu show up le crossit
permet d'avoir de répondre à tout ça
puis en plus tu vas avoir des résultats
moi ce que je veux savoir c'est
justement qu'est-ce que tu recherches
pour que je puisse te donner la bonne
réponse pour que je puisse justement te
dire oui c'est pour toi après ça mon gym
le Gym du GS d' à côté peu importe parce
qu'en terme d'horaur si tu veux venir
t'entraîner à 10h le matin j'ai pas de
cours bon ça marchera pas il faut qu'on
offre service qui fonctionne pour toi
mais sinon en général les gens qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent ils veulent avoir du fun
pu il veulent avoir des résultats puis
ça ça passe par la constance ouais si tu
do être constant parce que le Crosset
justement c'est varié fait que les gens
en général en terme de motivation ben tu
as plus besoin de te fier à ça parce que
vu que les choses changent régulièrement
ça te garde plus engagé dans le
processus les gens voient les résultats
fait même chose tuas pas BES être motivé
tu vois que tu t'améliores ah au bout de
3 mois je suis plus fort je suis plus
rapide je me sens mieux dans ma peau
j'ai plus confiance je dors mieux je je
snack moins tuas plein de
changement cette cette perception de
motivation là
idéalement tu as la même aller
t'entraîner au dans un gym conventionnel
où est-ce que tu peux rentrer tu mets
tes écouteurs tu fais tes trucs ça
répond à différents types de personnes
si tu es capable de faire ça tant mieux
mais si justement tu es comme j'arrive
au gym pu là moi faut que je décide ce
que j'ai à faire ben viens chez nous je
vais m'occuper de toi fait tu sais c'est
un petit peu ça c'est qu'est-ce que tu
recherches puis moi à la limite tu dis
ce que tu recherches capable de dire si
c'est la bonne chose que tu vas
retrouver chez nous ou potentiellement
dans un autre gym ou si tu es mieux
justement de va marcher dors plus
ouais tu as besoin de dormir là tu sais
comme honnêtement tout le monde est
fatigué pu tout Semin c'est super
important puis souvent c'est ça là tu
sais c'est pas de t'entraîner plus qui
va t'amener plus de résultats ça va être
de te reposer puis de relaxer puis gérer
d'autres aspects sais nous autres c'est
vraiment ça au gym qu'on essaie de faire
c'est répondre à ton besoin puis ton
besoin puis de parler aux gens puis où
est-ce qu'on va justement aller
maximiser dans le fond l'effort que tu
vas faire parce que est-ce que ton
effort c'est d'ê coucher 1 heure plus
tôt ou est-ce que ton effort c'est de te
réveiller un peu plus tôt puis de venir
au gym ou le soir ou venz la fin de
semaine nou peu importe mais on a toutes
24 he dans une journée puis on a toutes
nos responsabilités fait même si tu tu
voudrais t'entraîner CIN fois semaine
peut-être que deux c'est correct puis si
tu fais ça 50 semaines par année mais
c'est sans workout c'est déjà beaucoup
c'est déjà beaucoup pu des fois c'est
juste de le verbaliser comme ça les gens
je me suis juste entraîné de j'ai juste
fait ça ouais mais c'est plus que genre
si tu avais rien fait que rien
exactement c'est toutes ces petites
choses là puis genre c'est souvent ça
qui qui va faire en sorte justement que
les gens vont vont continuer puis qui
qui vont vouloir justement s'entraîner
puis mettre un peu d'effort làdedans la
courbe de progrès moi tu sais la mettons
la première année en fait le premier
mois que j'ai commencé là tu sais en
fait jeis arrivé là puis dans le temps
j'étais à Québec un à Québec c'était
quand même du bon volume là Gy là tu
sais puis là j'éis arrivé là puis pour
vrai les premières séances j'étais là
mais c'est impossible je me rappelle il
m'avait appelé en fait il était genre
sur un banc couché sur le dos puis genre
je sais pas pourquoi je t'appelis je
pense en tout cas puis tu je viens de
finir ma séance puis là genre je pense
pas que je vais être capable de me
lever cétait vraiment c'était vraiment
intense puis sais justement tu sais
j'avais tu sais pu après ça c'est à
chacun genre comment comment gager son
son effort puis tu sais ça va connaître
ses limites pu tu sais moi je venais
d'un monde de compétition j'ais dire en
plus comm c'est ça c'est les types de
personnes les plus dangereuses parce que
les gens qui ont fait du sport avant
moiou volball au secondaire j'ai cont
l'université je fais duing l'aviron
comme j'ai toujours fait des sports
compétitifsce que tu te présentes il
faut que tu tu fasses tuaccomplisse ton
effort ça c'est dangereux parce que nous
on arrive dans un gym puis tu sais ce
que tu as fait dans le passé tu sais
c'est quoi te pousser mentalement puis
tu sais aussi c'est quoi pas te pousser
ouais puis ça tu veux justement être
saingne fait les gens se donnent tu es
comme là tu es
over trop fait nous les coach sa on le
sait là moi j'aurais voulu que tu fasses
j'aurais dit fais juste la moitié tu
aurais fait faire au moins TR mon coach
il me disait e genre prend une BAR vide
ou tu me dis que c'est ta première fois
si j'é toi je relaxer un pe c'est ça
c'est sûr que je l'ai pas écouté pu
c'est moim-même qui s mis dans cette
situation là tu sais mais justement tu
sais puis là les premières fois je tquis
tout le monde avoir une bonne technique
puis être capable de faire des Liv puis
être capable de faire des des muscle
puis j'étais comme genre je j'tais je
ser jamais est capable de faire ça tu
sais je me rendrai jamais là puis
mettons la les le premier mois j'étais
comme à chaque
séance là jeéis raqué pendant des jours
j' comme je comprends pas comment que le
monde font je l peut-être juste pas pour
moi puis une fois tu passes ça ouais
puis là tu commences à réussir tes
premiers tu sais tes premiers mouvements
techniquement tu es pas capable de faire
tu es capable de faire une coupe de de P
puis la première fois que tu réussis un
M tout puis le progrès je trouve il est
vraiment euh tangible puis tu sais comme
c'est c'est c'est vraiment tu sais
justement au niveau des livres tu il y a
un chiffre tu j'éis j'étais pas capable
de faire ça maintenant je suis capable
de faire ça ou tel mouvement un insttin
PUP j'étais pas capable de le faire là
je suis capable de le faire puis il y a
vraiment quelque chose moi j' le feeling
j'éis en train de devenir un surom non
mais tu sais vraiment le progrès qu'on
voit il est vraiment le fun puis
motivant puis on dirait il dure
longtemps tu sais puis quand tu sais
mettons quand on fait laanotation quand
tu arrivrive à certain niveau à mener le
progrès et
une seconde sur 7 ans de natation oua
mais seconde là à F ou oua ou c'est s
s de c'est le fun de voir des nouveaux
tu sais pu nous aut on le dit tout le
temps tu 3 4 semaines M d'adaptation au
début comme prends ça molo tu sais le
plus possible mais après ça tu as comme
là tu tombes que justement les
mouvements tu les as appris les ns là
quand tu arrives tu lis table tu es
capable de lire tu es capable de lire le
tableau tu es comme puis là tu commences
à pouvoir metton rajouter un peu de poid
parce que tu es capable de faire tel et
tel mouvement puis là il y a une espèce
de courbe sur 3 mois ou tout des pur
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps à Mané il arrive des petits
plateaux puis c'est ces plateaux là qui
sont intéressant parce que là des fois
c'est comme ah pu là ils viennent poser
des questions pu là c'est comme ouais
mais attends un peu tu sais continue à
travailler dessus puis là ou ça débloque
là tuas un autre de mois ou oh p p p des
petit plateaux tu sais comme faut juste
les prendre un un petit plateau à la
fois tu sais c'est pour moi c'est la
beauté genre de juste l'exercice
physique tu fait peu importe que tu fais
c'est justement si tu es constant puis
assidu tu vas les voir tu vas voir cette
progression là puis en tant qu'adulte on
tu all à l'école tu avais des tests à
toutes les mois machin sais tu as tout
le temps une note tuas tout le temps
quelque chose dire c tu es bon ou moins
bon si tuas performé ou quoi que ce soit
puis là tu arrives dans le monde adulte
tu peut-être une évaluation de ton boss
une fois par année ou quoi que ce soit
ou tu sais idéalement justement si tu en
relation tuas quelque chose de
positif mais l'entraînement c'est tu
fais quelque chose pendant un mois la
même chose tu vas t'améliorer puis c'est
genre tu le vois ça c'est c'est fun pour
nous autres les coaches moi c'est une
des plus belles chose c'est les gens se
rendent compte oh je suis bon oh je
m'améliore puis comme tu vois tout ce
côté làà puis c'est c'est tangible pour
les autres puis justement idéalement
mais tu veux que ça dure le plus
longtemps possible tu veux
continuer une aventure à long terme là
c'est pas 6 mois c'est de moin 2 ans de
moin 5 ans imagine si tu fais ça mais
deux ou trois fois par semaine pendant 5
ans imagine ce que tu fais sur 5 ans 6
mois jeis perdre jeis perdre 10 livres
en 30 jours tu comme non non donmi des
années puis genre on va voir la
transformation qui va se faire puis
c'est c'est rare où est-ce que tu peux
faire ça ailleurs apprendre à jouer de
la musique ou tu sais faut que tu
apprennes à faire quelque chose mais on
a pas autant de feedback dans notre vie
en général puis ça c'est un SP de beau
moyens que je
trouve tu lèves plus lourd tu vas plus
vite tu te sens mieux comme c'est c'est
tangible comme comme transformation à
matin on parlait on avait un autre
podcast ce matin puis on parlait
d'investissement là puis de comment
l'investissement comme cétait
exponentiel puis une phrase que j'avais
lu puis ça s'applique vraiment bien
maintenant c'est le monde ont tendance à
surestimer ce que tu peux faire en 1 an
mais sous-estimer ce que tu peux faire
en 10 ans ouais puis en en entraînement
moi je trouve vraiment parce que moi tu
sais je fais beaucoup de cours à pied
j'ai quand même une grosse tribune ses
réseaux sociaux fait que les gens ils me
posent des questions quand ils veulent
commencer la course à pied même si je
suis loin d'être un entraîneur puis loin
d'être qualifié pour donner des des
conseils mais moi j'ai tout le temps
genre si aujourd'hui tu fais 5 minutes
de course puis genre 5 minutes de course
5 minutes de marche pendant 20 minutes
là tu sais ou une minute une minute
ouais peut-être que là tu as
l'impression que c'est rien là tu sais
que c'est genre tu me regardes moi
courir tu fais lui il fait des des 50 km
c'est un malade tu sais mais comme
imagine si tu progresses en gardant la
constance imagine dans 10 ans ce que tu
vas faire c'est fou là puis
effectivement je l' jamais penser comme
ça que le sport quand tu commences c'est
tu à chaque jour tu as une gratification
qui dit amélioration c'est motivant ça
ça améliorer tout le temps puis on on tu
sa même chose à moins de prendre un
nouveau sport de l'exercice physique ou
d'apprendre à jouer un instrument ou
d'apprendre quelque chose nouvelle
langue peu importe comme on on perd on
perd comme adulte ça c'est quoi la
quantité de temps que ça prend pour ça
nous a pris combien de temps à apprendre
à lire et écrire pas mal sûr que nos
enseignantes au Prim tu sais comme ça
prend des années là comme on apprend
l'alphabet en maternel maisend c'est
long à prendre puis justement cette
perception là de temps elle change plus
qu'on vieillit plus que le temps
accelèire machin machin mais genre oui
j'ai besoin idéalement d'anné puis c'est
là où est-ce que ça ça te prend de la
patience puis il faut avoir une vision à
long terme mais puis même chose quand
que les gens commencent à réaliser ça
dans la salle d'entraînement ben ils
vont le réaliser dans d'autres aspects
de leur vie c'est là où est-ce que
justement comme c'est c'est la beauté de
la choseou h h puis une des un des
aspects aussi qu'on a qu'on a moins
parlé duoss je trouve qui fait partie de
l'attrait moi j'ai jamais été ça jamais
été ce qui m'a attiré mettant parce que
moi je vois là pour m'entraîner pu
justement le fait que ça soit 1 heure
j'arrive je m'entraî je m'en va puis pas
je parle pas je parle au monde là mais
dans le sens que je t écouteurs tu
arrives t écouteurs je parle écouteurs
sauf que tu sais dans dans le sens que
moi c'est jamais l'aspect social
communauté qui m'a attiré au CrossFit
mais je trouve quand même que c'est
vraiment fort puis présent C de mon
expérience où est-ce que je suis allé tu
sais justement la gangne de 7h le matin
ou la gangne sais il se cré vraiment des
il se cré des vrais amitiés CR des vrais
gangs c'est une vraie communauté puis
justement qui s'entrevalorise entre ell
puis je pense que pour vraiment beaucoup
de monde ça leur fait V beaucoup de bien
là bah tu sais techniquement tu passes 3
à 5 heures par semaine avec les mêmes
gens tu sais ou ve pas des amitiés qui
vont se qui vont se former là-dedans là
ça pas le choix comment c'est dans pro
est-ce que c'est camaraderie ou c'est
genre game face quand c'est la game mais
généralement c'est camaraderie là
mais oui tu sais on a du fun B en tout
cas moi j'ai du fun les autres après ils
feront ce qu'ils voudront là mais j'ai
bien de fun avec ceux que je connais tu
sais les les autres Canadiens on a tout
le temps bien du fun sais comme ici au
Québec on est on est chanceux on a comme
on est on est quoi quatre 4 4 C gars
compétitif là fait c'est c'est
intéressant on vient tout de la même
place on peut se parler en français
parce que tu quand on voit à
l'international tout le temps tout en
anglais tout le temps aux États-Unis
nous autres c'est c'est c'est le fun
d'arriver là-bas pu pouir juste comme E
je peux juste parler en français puis
for à parler en français ouais c'est ça
des fois je force d'autres à parler en
français avec moi mais euh non
d'habitude ça va mais tu sais mettons si
on parle pendant les Games c'est sûr au
début tout le monde a un peu plus
d'énergie pu un plus de bandwid fait que
c'est comme plus friendly puis plus ça
avance dans le weekend plus ça devient
sérieux puis tu sais aussi comme le
dénouement de la compétition souvent
c'est c'est un peu serré fait que tu
sais ça le stress augmente mais moi j'ai
j'ai quand même à date j'ai réussi à
rester quand même ch tout le long là
mais non ça va bien tu sais entre les
gars ça ça va relativement bien après ça
entre les filles je sais pas on les voit
jamais son sont tellement sur un hor
différent je sais pas comment ça va les
équipes même chos on les croise
quasiment jamais mais mais il y a pas
d'affaire de de mind games là ou de dans
le sens que tu sa je sais pas il y a des
sports comme Mons juste dans le je pense
des fois les gars vont s'envoyer des
pointes pour essayer de jouer dans tête
de l'AAU déstabiliser l'ut ça existe en
CrossFit ça l' que ça existe je pensais
pas que ça avait autant d'effet mais ça
oui ça existeis il y a moyen de faire je
veux dire c'est de la compétition hein
c'est ça ça en fait partie puis si tu
déstabilises ton ton adversaire ben tuas
automatiquement une avantage tu sais
fait que c'est c'est juste de le faire
d'une façon qui reste amicale mais tu
sais ça dépend toujours de la perception
des autres on pas contrôler ça on avait
un gars avec qui on nait au secondaire
euh qui arrivait en arrière du bloc qui
disait gen il parlait vraiment il était
vraiment vocal ah je suis pété j'étais
malade toute la nuit genre ça por pas
puis il part à bloc son 400 m le gars à
côté easy aujourd'hui ça va être light
work final il se fait péter dans le
premier s ça le C dans sa
tteou ça c'est c'est arrivé c'est arrivé
une fois dans le passé justement avec
Pat arrivé une compétition puis il y
avait de l' Poké quand même ça va pas
bien il avait mal partout puis il
commence les compétition puis il arrache
tout le monde tu mentais en pleine face
c'est super mais tu sais en même temps
moi je suis pas ce type de personne là
comme tu me dis tu es pét F so p
faire mon affaire pareil puis après le
résultat c'est le résultat tu sais si tu
es plus fit que moi tu es plus fit que
moi puis je suis prête à à l'admettre tu
sais mais je suis pas une personne très
très sentimentale de ce côtél parce que
à part sais à part peut-être la course
où est-ce que là tu sais vous partagez
le même espace c'est vraiment chacun
pour soi vraiment d'incidence sur b b
les gars ils se sont rentrés dedans pas
mal il y a eu des accidents en bik comme
c'est j'étais comme est-ce que vous
parliez un peu au moins p parce que tu
sais il y a une certaine strat comme
d'autres dans le Ploton dans avant on
vous tiriz là tirait un peu après àé
quand qu'on commen à être fatigué le
meilleur était pas mal tout le temps en
avant puis on on l'a pas mal on l'a pas
mal laissé en tout cas moi je l' laissé
en avant mais ça draft tant que ça parce
que vous étiez quand même sur des gros
bikes dans gazon là fa ça faisait une
bonne différence avant avant que ça
commence je comme on tourne tellement il
y avait beaucoup CIT beaucoup de
serpents puis il y avait deux stit quand
même ben c'était pas très long mais sa
céit ça avait de l'air long quand tu
étais dessus ça faisait du bien puis
j'étais comme quand j'étais en premier
en avant j'étais comme ça ah ouais ça
tirait fort pu là je tombais deè enre
c'est plus facile j'essayis de rester
deè plus sou mais sais on était quand
même relativement comme on était correct
je l'ai pas laissé sécher en avant tout
le long comme moi j'ai fait quasiment un
lap au complet parce qu'on était 4 ça
s'est switché 45 là ça s switché mais en
arrière là il y en a qui ont crashé les
rentrer dedans puis jeis comme ok att un
peu tu sais tu peux tu peux trash si tu
veux mais essaie de pas te planter dans
les autres là ouais essaie de pas finir
la game des autres mais je pense pas que
c'était par exprès mais c'est comme tu
peux faire un peu plus attention
peut-être ouais ouais je pense qu' a
quand même une belle camaraderie du côté
tu sa même chose du côté des hommes des
femmes on sait pas mais on en parle pas
pas parce qu'on veut pas en parler par
connait aucunement mais tu sais sont 40
gars à faire ça sont 40 à se rendre aux
Games puis à faire ça pu je pense que
dans n'importe quel sp tu as quand même
une certaine forme de respect fa autant
que Tuch ou pas ou quoi que ce soit je
veux dire il y a quand même ça se fait
sur une base de puis moi c'est c'est une
des choses justement que que je vois au
qu je sais ce que ce que lui il met à
toutes les jours comme effort pour se
rendre là ben moi je regarder 39 autes
gars comme vous faites ça aussi là comme
je vous lève mon chapeau puis vous avez
mon mon respect on le faire le fun là
mais genre tu sais c'est c'est c'est
quand même ça c'est quand même une belle
atmosphère c'est possible de de de bien
gagner sa vie comme athlète pro en
CrossFit ou quand tu gages Mme
po c'est celui qui gagne les Games est
correct mett tu es tu es 35e tu sais m
le SPIR est trop jeune en ce moment puis
sais justement il y a pas assez de fans
il y a pas assez de de marketing de
sponsor de C de ça fait ça sent ça sent
VI mais tu sa dans n'importe quel sport
je veux dire jokovic va va très bien sa
vie numéro 33 je je sais pas comment qui
s'appelle mais sûement correct aussi par
exemple ou parce parce que justement ça
fait beaucoup plus long
dans les mêmes
proportion les gens au top vont bien
vivre plus que tu descends mais ça
dépend justement de la profondeur du
sport puis de est-ce qu'il y a des
limitations de CrossFit pour les
sponsors personnels est-ce que CrossFit
il interviennent pas du tout dans les
sponsur personnels j'imagine que là il y
a quand même une bonne avenue oui ou
ouiir une coupe de courriel j'imagine
que c'est ben moi c'est plus des
renouvellements parce que j'avais déjà
des sponsors fait que la table de no
avec une nouvelle carte pour le
renouvement on va renouveler mais voici
mon CV mtenant je modifi mon CV ici si
c'est pas mal
ça fait c'est sûr les prix ont augmenté
un peu là ça commence à être vraiment
intéressant mais tu sais
comme ce qui est plate de ça c'est que
tu sais la la une carrière de gross
c'est vraiment court sais Mons les
joueurs d'cky ils font des millions mais
ils font ça pendant 20 ans tu sais ça
vaut vraiment la peine moi pour ça
tantôt je disais faut que j'é la sauce
un peu essayer d'aller en chercher le
plus possible comme ça quand je va arrê
c'est ton année vachalé là ça veut dire
si tu gagnes l'année prochaine c'est
comme ton ta fenêtre d'opportunité
vachalé ouais c'est ça faut continuer à
gagner pour Ben plus possible pour les
quelques années qui s'en viennent puis
on se fait un Coupin après ça on arrête
ouais mais tu étais quand même capable
de de pas avoir avoir une job de jour
puis P travailler j'ai j'ai arrêté de
travailler la construction en 2019 je
pense ça fait quand même une coupe
d'années que je travaille pas là ok fait
faut que tu fasses le saut quand même
moment donn c'est ça c'est les premières
années ben on divise sur les années en
arrière où est-ce que justement cétait
très puis là tu sais dans le fond les
années où est-ce qu'on va éidalement
bien performer pu faire plus d'argent
ben on divise sur les années où est-ce
qu'on va prendre notre retraite fait oui
c'est payant mais tu sais pour en vivre
d'une vie c'est relatifou faire des bons
choix ouais c'est ça mais là vous avez
un gym ou oui justement avant de vous
laisser comment les
gens vous contactent comment les gens
vous suivent c'est quoi c'est le temps
de faire les plogs là toutes les plogs
moi j'ai juste Instagram je suis un
petit peu vieux jeu j'ai eu Instagram
juste à cause de CrossFit fait que j'ai
une page Facebook mais vous allez pas
avoir des
réponses sinon non le Gym CrossFit
wonderland.com c'est le site web on a un
Instagram aussi c'est là qu'on est
surtout actif puis si les gens veulent
nous rejoindre par courriel c'est on a
on essaie de tout centraliser fait
l'information va être sur sur ouais
Instagram c'est c'est nos médias sociaux
on fait ça pour le fun pour highlight
nos m qu'est-ce qu'on fait tout
l'information est vraiment sur le site
web puis le mode de communication en en
a un c'est courriel ok simple parfait
merci beaucoup de vre temp super yes
puis bonne chance pour la saison qui s
vient merci beaucoup al right